SPEAKER: Winner of the 2017
Olivier Award for Best Musical,
and based on the iconic
film, "Groundhog Day,"
this is the new Broadway hit
that Entertainment Weekly
calls "a wonderfully inventive
show with dazzling energy,
creativity, wit, and heart."
And New York One says,
"this is a Groundhog Day
to celebrate with Danny Rubin's
wryly humorous book, Matthew
Warchus's inventive direction,
and Tim Minchin's clever songs,
the forecast for this Groundhog
Day looks pretty bright."
Let's roll you a
little commercial,
get you in the mood.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[? - ?] There's a new
best musical on Broadway
that you'll want to see
again, and again, and again.
The New York Times
says, "I loved it."
"It's a miracle on Broadway."
"Groundhog Day."
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
ANDY KARL: Well, that was fun.
Everybody enjoy the commercial?
That was a short commercial.
Got anything longer?
I mean, hi, everybody.
I'm glad you're all here.
We're going to sing
some songs for you.
This first song from
the show is called--
well, it's not the
first song in the show.
It actually happens
on day three,
after Phil has repeated the
day the third time, completely
freaked out, looks for
help, can't get any.
So what's the next idea?
Let's get drunk and deal with
this by putting all of it
in a bottle.
So he goes to this bar.
I play Phil Connors.
I'm Andy Karl.
RAY LEE: I'm Raymond J Lee.
I play Ralph.
JORDAN GRUBB: I'm Jordan Grubb.
I play Gus.
ANDY KARL: They're the barflies.
JORDAN GRUBB: Yeah.
RAY LEE: Yeah.
JORDAN GRUBB: We're
the local yokels.
RAY LEE: Yeah, so we're drunk.
And he comes and
hangs out with us.
It's a fun scene.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JORDAN GRUBB (SINGING):
I wake up hung over.
I go to bed smashed.
Like an alcoholic hamster on one
of them little wheelie things.
Every evening the same,
every morning the pain.
I start drinking at 10.
Hell, by noon I'm
not feeling things.
And nobody cares what
I'm talking about.
RAY LEE (SINGING): Oh shit, I
just got throw up in my mouth.
JORDAN GRUBB (SINGING):
Just swallow it, man.
RAY LEE (SINGING): I'm trying
JORDAN GRUBB (SINGING):
Just swallow it.
Your opinions or your vomit,
either way they're unwanted.
And I think I had a point
there, but the point
is it don't matter.
Because it's pointless
having points anyway.
Nobody cares what I say.
Nobody cares what I do.
And what's the
point in bothering
BOTH (SINGING): --if no
one else is bothered.
I was born in this town.
And I'm going to die here too.
I wake with a headache.
I take a piss.
I often miss.
I often get a little
bit on the floor.
I eat a piece of toast that I
found toasted in the toaster
then I go to get my jacket
by the rack by the back door.
And then I get into my truck and
drive a block to Raphie's shop.
It's always shut.
I pick him up and drive
us up to Running Rock
and shoot some cans,
and crack some cans,
and shoot the breeze about
the weather, or a sports team,
or a car.
And after that the bar.
Nobody cares what I say.
Nobody cares what I do.
Yeah, what's the
point in bothering
if no one else is bothered?
I was born in this town.
And I'm going to die here too.
ANDY KARL: Wait a minute.
There's no tomorrow tomorrow.
We can do whatever we want!
BOTH (SINGING): We can
do whatever we want!
ANDY KARL: I'm driving.
JORDAN GRUBB: Woohoo!
ALL (SINGING): I
wake with a headache.
I take a piss.
I often miss.
I often get a little
bit on the floor.
I sometimes try to clean the
mess I make from my mistakes.
But for who's sake am I making
all this effing effort for?
I wake up each morning
in the same damn day.
There seems to be jack
shit that I can do or say.
I got no voice.
I got no vote.
I've got no way to
change a goddamn thing.
JORDAN GRUBB: Uh, I
think that's the pigs?
ANDY KARL: Who gives a fig?
ALL (SINGING): Nobody cares what
I Do Nobody cares if I'm alive.
Utterly uninfluential, no
regrets, and no potential,
every turn inconsequential.
ANDY KARL: Let's drive!
ALL (SINGING): Nobody
cares what I say.
Nobody cares about my life,
utterly uninstrumental,
no insurance, no intent.
RAY LEE: Actually,
I've got dental.
JORDAN GRUBB: Really?
Well, that's nice.
And I'm not sure
what the point is,
but the point is
it don't matter.
ANDY KARL: Oh, I see him.
RAY LEE: Oh, mister.
ANDY KARL: I think he's
gonna swerve first.
ALL (SINGING): Nobody
cares what I do.
Nobody cares if I'm alive,
utterly uninfluential,
no regrets, and no potential,
every turn inconsequential.
ANDY KARL: Utterly
repercussion-free.
JORDAN GRUBB: Though
arguably not for that tree.
RAY LEE: I think I
pooped my dungaree!
ALL (SINGING): No
consequence at all.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDY KARL: Nobody cares!
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
OK, I think I'm up next.
My name is Rebecca Faulkenberry.
I play Nancy Taylor in the show.
And in one of the incarnations
of Phil's Groundhog Day,
I am a one-night stand for him,
after he learns that I'm Nancy
Taylor--
Lincoln High, Mrs Walsh's
class, for any fan of the film.
And so that's how you
kind of meet me in Act I.
And then, surprise,
in Act II, I get
to open it with this
song, which kind of gives
you a bit more insight
into who Nancy Taylor is.
So this song, I play
Nancy in the show.
And put on your
thinking caps for this.
It's called "Playing Nancy."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY (SINGING):
Well, here I am again,
the pretty but naive one,
the perky-breasted, giggly,
one-night stand.
Is it my destiny to be
a brief diversion, just
a detour on the
journey of some man?
I'm not really one for asking.
I'll play whatever
role I'm cast in,
will smile with perfect
teeth, and grimace underneath.
I learned back in my teens,
there's no point in protesting.
If you look good in
tight jeans, that's
what they'll want
you dressed in,
once you're known
for low cut tops.
It's pretty hard to stop.
It isn't easy to break
free of playing Nancy.
I don't really remember.
I guess I chose to be here.
I wasn't quite aware that I
was put here to be stared at.
But this world I chose to
live in is mostly run by men.
So you take what you are given
just to feel the love again.
So throughout the endless week,
and all through the weekend,
you will find me
here, playing Nancy.
And look, I know
this person fits me.
I'm pretty good at being pretty.
And I'm grateful, I
mean to say, there
are worse roles you could play.
And I'd rather be up dancing
than sad against the wall.
It's better to be leered
at than not desired at all.
Who am I to dream of better?
To dream that one day,
I will be something
more than just collateral
in someone else's battle.
I will be something
more than Nancy.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
- Very nice, very nice.
BARRETT DOSS: So we're up next.
I'm Barrett Doss.
I play Rita Hanson in the show.
So she is Phil's
associate producer, played
by Andie McDowell in the movie.
And so after some time
in the second act,
Phil has kind of reached
the end of his rope
and reveals finally to Rita
what he's been going through.
And whether or not she believes
him, I guess we don't know yet.
But she offers her, sort of
her interpretation of what
she would do if she were in the
position that he's been put in.
Anything else, Andy?
ANDY KARL: That
sounded great to me.
BARRETT DOSS: Oh thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BARRETT DOSS
(SINGING): Sometimes
it's like I'm stumbling
forward, hustled forward,
jostled from behind by time.
And sometimes it's like
I'm being dragged, yet
always lagging, trying to
keep in time with time.
But if I could stop the
clock for just one day,
if I could freeze a
moment for a moment,
rest before the measure's over,
hold the beat for just one day,
If I could wind
it back and start
afresh, just a day
to catch my breath,
to make mistakes
and set them right,
to lay the calming of the night.
If I had my time again, I
would do it all the same.
They say, but that's insane.
Wouldn't you want to
make a couple of changes?
Regrets, I'd not
even have a few,
if I could do this thing
that you say you can do.
I always dreamt of
learning how to dance.
ANDY KARL (SINGING): Some
days I go out without pants.
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING):
It's so exciting--
ANDY KARL (SINGING): I
slept with 90% of women--
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING): --a
new beginning every morning--
ANDY KARL (SINGING):
--in Punxsutawney--
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING):
--to have the time
to strive for more.
ANDY KARL (SINGING):
--between 18 and 84.
And one dude when I was bored.
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING):
If I had my time
again I'd take the
path less trodden,
avoid the crap I trod in
and read a lot of books.
ANDY KARL (SINGING): I've
stolen 18 million bucks.
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING):
And I would worry less
about my looks.
ANDY KARL (SINGING): And
I guess I'll do it again.
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING): Next
time I would be a lot more zen.
And I would punch a
lot of men If I had--
BOTH (SINGING): --my time again.
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING):
If I had my time again,
I would do it all the same.
They claim that
that's ridiculous.
Surely you'd want to
make a couple of fixes.
All those boxes left
unchecked, all the
dreams you left neglected,
you'd go back and put it right.
I'd always fancied
learning how to climb.
ANDY KARL (SINGING): I once
masturbated seven times--
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING):
I'd study math--
ANDY KARL (SINGING):
--in the bath--
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING):
--in search for meaning.
ANDY KARL (SINGING):
--in one evening.
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING):
And I'd run uphill.
ANDY KARL (SINGING): It
wasn't fun, but still--
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING): I'd
learn to paint, just to know--
ANDY KARL (SINGING): --a man
my age, it's nice to know--
BOTH (SINGING): I can.
ANDY KARL (SINGING):
It's nice to know I can.
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING):
If I had my time again,
I'd sample all the
samples, look at things
from different angles.
I would not do it all the
same if I had my time again.
ANDY KARL: Now an
interlude of music.
There's a tilt-a-whirl on stage.
It's pretty fantastic.
BARRETT DOSS: Yeah.
ANDY KARL: Five revolves, it's
getting your money's worth.
BARRETT DOSS: High
tech, just like Google.
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING):
If I had my time again,
the things I'd handle better,
I would send my unsent letters.
ANDY KARL (SINGING): I
have started 700 fights.
And if you knew
the endless nights
that I have wasted getting
wasted, contemplating
different ways to suicide.
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING): I
would write, and I would ride.
ANDY KARL (SINGING):
And I have tried
every food, and every
trick, and every choice,
and every cheat
a thousand times.
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING):
And I would bring joy
to other people's lives.
ANDY KARL (SINGING): And I
did eat about a dozen donuts
and I don't know
why, and I don't know
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING):
And I would learn piano.
ANDY KARL (SINGING): Why.
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING): And
I would make a lot of friends
if I had my time.
BOTH (SINGING): If I had my time
again, I'd open all the doors.
I'd never look behind before.
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING): And
oh, the things I'd taste,
the things I'd try.
ANDY KARL (SINGING): Oh I, I
was completely dead inside.
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING): And
misery, I could prevent.
ANDY KARL (SINGING):
But today I'm like 85%.
BARRETT DOSS (SINGING): And I
would make a lot of friends,
if I had my time again!
ANDY KARL (SINGING):
Again, I have had it.
I have had my time again.
I've had--
BOTH (SINGING): --my time again!
ANDY KARL: So our
last song, don't go.
BARRETT DOSS: Wait, [INAUDIBLE].
Q and A, Q and A, Q and
A, Q and A, Q and A.
SPEAKER: Q and A, we're talking.
ANDY KARL: We do a Q and
A, and then we do a song?
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
We don't have a song.
We might have a song.
BARRETT DOSS: He's never
sung that song before.
ANDY KARL: I was gonna
go a capella with it.
SPEAKER: Bring your chairs
up to the red lines here,
folks, spike marks.
So we got visual spike marks.
You've heard of
those before, yeah?
All right.
BARRETT DOSS: Our floor, our
stage is covered in them,
at the theater.
It's like confetti.
- How do you keep
them all straight?
You said five revolves.
So for those who
don't know, revolves
are like the turntables, the
spinning things on the stage.
And I thought, I was impressed
with "Hamilton" the first time
I saw two on stage.
And I was like, oh
great, "Hamilton," yeah.
And--
BARRETT DOSS: What
is "Hamilton"?
- This little thing.
ANDY KARL: Never heard of it.
- "Hamilton" day.
And, but you guys have five.
So there's an outer,
and then a semi outer,
and then inside,
and then there's
three in the middle that
are like doing their things.
There's so much I want to
talk about this, part of which
is the set design
itself, which I
want to also bring
in the guy who
wrote the original
screenplay from the movie,
and the book for this
show, Danny Rubin, which
should appear, boom,
on screen right now.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY: Ah, magic!
[APPLAUSE]
ANDY KARL: We've
actually, we've been
watching him right here
watch us the entire time.
He's been singing every
song along with us.
It's been the weirdest thing.
BARRETT DOSS: He's been down
there drinking water and doing
all sorts--
DANNY RUBIN: I just love
hanging with you guys.
BARRETT DOSS: Just
like old times.
SPEAKER: It's like literal
dance interpretation
for all the lyrics.
That's always fun to do.
So Danny, can you speak real
quick to what the process was.
How did this ever
get from your mind
onto the page in the
first place in '93,
with the late, great Harold
Ramis, you co-wrote, and then
now to on the Broadway stage?
How did this whole
process start?
DANNY RUBIN: Well, I was
looking for an idea for a move.
I was a screenwriter.
And I needed to write a movie.
My agent said, you need
to write another one.
I said OK.
And I was just
brainstorming ideas.
And that's how I came
up with that one.
And I wrote the script.
And I sent it out
into the ether.
And Harold Ramis found it.
That's how we wound up
working together on the film.
SPEAKER: Wow.
And then--
DANNY RUBIN: You said quickly.
I can tell [INAUDIBLE]
much longer.
SPEAKER: No, that is great.
And then, so fast forward
over almost 25 years later.
First off, is anybody not
familiar with the story?
Everybody here knows, good.
All right, phew.
All right, for anybody watching
online, pause right now,
go watch the movie, come back,
listen to the soundtrack.
All right, how did
it get to the stage?
How did you make a
musical out of this?
DANNY RUBIN: For years and
years, really very soon
after the movie came
out, I was thinking, boy,
this would make a great musical.
And I'd like to do that.
And so I spent many years taking
notes, meeting with people,
having ideas.
I wasn't in any hurry.
I was just starting
to collect things.
It finally reached critical
mass after about 15 years.
And all through that
time I was getting calls
from people in the
theater world saying,
hey, I just had this great idea.
Wouldn't "Groundhog Day"
make a great musical?
I said, yeah, let's
talk about it.
And after years of doing that
and having never really hitting
the right people at the
right moment, Matthew Warchus
called me up and said, hey, do
you think "Groundhog Day" would
make a good musical?
I said, absolutely, great idea.
And then introduced
me to Tim Minchin.
And we were off and running.
SPEAKER: So how did Tim then,
how did Tim get attached?
DANNY RUBIN: Because
he and Matthew
are attached at the hip.
And when you get one,
you get the other.
SPEAKER: Fair enough.
And then for all of
you on stage now,
it was originally
workshopped, of course,
or not even workshopped
in one [INAUDIBLE]..
It went up like full
production in London.
Were any of you involved in
that production out there?
ANDY KARL: Me.
I went in as the American,
came out the American.
SPEAKER: You didn't
change nationalities
while you were there?
ANDY KARL: No, no, no,
though London is lovely.
And they really embraced
the musical there.
It was very well-received there.
So that was fun.
And it was a
fantastic experience.
We spent most of the time--
I was there for five months.
And most of that time
was actually figuring out
how those five revolves work.
Because what Matthew
Warchus is is
sort of a mathematician who
can also give you emotions.
So it's two things at
once that are happening.
And the floor moves within
an inch of its life.
And it's very important.
It actually, it
affects our story.
The way that it revolves
is kind of like a clock.
So every day, rewind--
SPEAKER: Symbolism.
ANDY KARL: --every
day moves forward.
And when the end of
the show, it changes.
And then every revolve
revolves alone of itself.
So it tells stories.
And it makes it very cinematic.
And it's a beautiful
show to watch.
But that took a lot
of time to figure out,
and also just making sure
that the scenes worked out
the way they did.
I think they discovered
a lot of things there.
And then we came here.
And with this incredible cast,
refined it even more to really
sort of eliminate
the things you don't
need with a show, which
is what you find out
as you're doing a show.
It's like, you know what?
We don't need it.
We're telling that with
movement or whatever.
But the show moves fast.
But it's also tells
an incredible journey
within those 2 and 1/2 hours.
SPEAKER: And then
for the rest of you,
how did you get attached
to the New York production?
BARRETT DOSS: Auditioned.
I mean, I had auditioned
prior to it moving to London,
but I had to put that--
sadly, even I couldn't continue
with my audition process
because I got a different
job, which was very fun.
But you know, but I
just cross my fingers
and hoped that it
would come back around.
And it ultimately did.
And I went back and
auditioned again.
SPEAKER: Back around.
BARRETT DOSS: Yeah, right?
SPEAKER: Symbolism.
BARRETT DOSS: Yeah,
and I auditioned again.
And this time, it
actually all worked out,
which was really great.
Andy forgot to say he also left
London and then came back here
and won an Olivier
Award afterwards
for this role, which is
amazing, along with the show.
So yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER: Yes.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
Yes, same with auditions.
They did have round of auditions
in May, April, May of last year
before they did the production
in London, and had some offers.
But that's always loose in
this business, as far as,
it's an offer, but is the show
actually going to come in?
And are they going
to change the parts
so that in four or
five months' time,
it's not what you
auditioned for,
so you don't actually
have that offer anymore?
So I got my, quote,
unquote, offer in May,
and then waited until,
I think it's probably
in October, November to
get an official offer.
But for those months
I was like, OK,
it did really well in London, so
that has good potential for it.
OK, it's changed producers.
Oh, but they still
have the money.
So OK, it's happening.
OK, do they have a theater?
OK, they have a theater.
OK, I haven't got an
official offer, though.
They're doing re-auditions.
But they didn't
audition my part.
OK, so, and you kind of go
through all these actor things,
but so yeah.
JORDAN GRUBB: I feel like I
was one of the last people
to join the company because
I had friends auditioning
all summer, and like in
May and stuff like that.
And I was out of town.
And I couldn't get in.
And I just thought,
oh man, I would
love to be a part of this show.
I mean, I loved the
movie growing up.
And I had heard it was
amazing over in London.
So then I had resigned
myself, like, I wasn't going
to have any work in the winter.
Because usually all that stuff
auditions in the late summer
and the fall.
And then November rolled
around and like a thing
for my track opened up.
And I was lucky.
And like, by January
was starting rehearsals.
But that just shows
you how quickly things
can change in our business.
ANDY KARL: And I got
to say, I mean we had--
he's one of our swings,
which is a task in itself,
because as I said, this is
a very complicated show.
Everything is timed out.
The characters
are very specific.
I think you had to cover
three roles in the same show
the other day, where he
was like the Sheriff,
but also Buster
combined, and then
throwing like shirts on me,
and doing all these things
that only like five
humans usually do.
And to this show,
it's such a credit
to have you here with
the show, just watching
what you did the other day.
and also appearing here today,
in place of some
of our other cast.
So it's fantastic.
We need you.
Thank you.
Thank you for auditioning
and being here.
JORDAN GRUBB: Thank you.
I definitely have gotten
like 500 more gray hairs
a week from it.
But I'm happily going gray.
I love the show.
RAY LEE: What's
happened too, where
like he's in costume for one
character and you're like,
lalala, it's going
to start, half hour.
Places, actually
something happened.
You've got to get
to this costume now.
We're going to hold the
show for five minutes.
He's in a whole other
costume, switching gears
and doing his other track.
And this show is tricky
because you're always
constantly moving,
because the floor moves,
your spike marks move.
So you're just like hunting
for stuff on the floor.
It's incredible what
our wonderful swings do.
SPEAKER: And Ray,
how did you get it?
RAY LEE: I was the
same with Becca.
I auditioned at the
same time as her.
They actually were like, OK,
you can go for Ralph or Gus.
Which part do you
want to go in for?
I said, I need a job.
So I'm going to try and
go for the tenor part.
Because everyone's going
to go for the lower track.
Went in, squeezed my balls, sang
those high notes in the room.
And then I found out I
got like a soft offer.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
Yeah, soft offer.
RAY LEE: Soft offer.
SPEAKER: A softer,
you got a softer.
RAY LEE: And like with Becca,
I was doing another gig
so I was out of town, but
constantly was on Twitter,
on message boards.
Like, people like the show.
People like the show, OK great.
You're trying to find
like clips online.
And then I got the
official offer in November.
And here I am.
SPEAKER: So I want to go back to
the costumes for a second, too.
Because Ray, you are not only
this character, this redneck
character, Ralph,
but you are Phil,
Phil the Groundhog.
So yeah, this giant--
that suit came from London.
RAY LEE: Yes, it did.
SPEAKER: It was made in London.
What is that like
wearing that groundhog,
in and out with the costume
changes too, because,
and it's hot and cumbersome.
RAY LEE: It is hot.
You can't really see.
But oh my gosh, I've
got my show body back.
I'm looking good this summer.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
Sweating it out.
RAY LEE: Sweating it out.
Do not burp in that costume
because it's disgusting.
You'll hotbox yourself.
BARRETT DOSS: How many
costume changes do you
have in the show, Ray?
RAY LEE: I have the second most.
I have 25 costume changes.
SPEAKER: Whoa.
RAY LEE: And Travis, who plays
Jeff in our cast, has 29.
He has the most.
SPEAKER: Because you're reliving
the same moments in the show
over and over again.
Danny, are you
allowed to tell us
how many times the day
repeats in the show?
There's like conspiracy
theories about how many it is.
There's no definite
answer that I could find.
DANNY RUBIN: I had to
sign something where
I'm not allowed to disclose.
The truth is, in my mind
it doesn't really matter.
It was just an
awful lot of days.
And I wouldn't want to end the
internet parlor game, in trying
to count how many it would be.
SPEAKER: So more than
10, less than 100.
We'll just leave it
about right there.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
More than 100.
SPEAKER: More than 100?
You think so?
Wow.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY: I think
people go into like, how long
does it take to learn French?
How long does it
take to learn piano?
How long?
And people go-- that's, I think,
where all the conspiracies come
because--
SPEAKER: Well, because there's
like montages within montages.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Yeah, so showing
that time has passed.
Yes, that is, yeah,
it's incredible.
And so all of you are not
only doing 100-plus days
in the same show, you're also
doing the same show eight times
a week.
Do you ever get tired?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
ANDY KARL: Tired right now.
What the hell am I doing here?
It's 1:30 in the afternoon.
I should be sleeping.
SPEAKER: How do you deal
with fatigue like that?
How do you keep it fresh, I
guess, within the same show,
literally, when you're doing
the same scene over and over?
ANDY KARL: I mean, everybody
in the show moves constantly.
There's not, it's
really an ensemble show.
I'm out there talking and
carrying some of the stories
along with some of
the text and stuff.
But everybody is
telling the same story
because we're repeating
and all that kind of stuff.
So we're all exhausted.
But it's such a great journey.
Every single night, people
are on their feet cheering
this show on because not
only is it hilarious,
it also goes very dark.
It goes very deep.
It goes into the heart.
And when you touch
people there, then
it becomes effected in a
way that you can't really
describe to somebody other than
just standing up and saying,
yes, that's the emotion.
But I think that's
what gets us through.
And also, I think
we love what we do.
BARRETT DOSS: And we
enjoy working together.
I think that's something
that's really come out
of all of the really,
really hard work
that our incredible ensemble
has done, and Andy's done.
And it's really
a group of people
that has learned to love each
other through some really
difficult challenges.
We've come up against
some stuff with this show.
And it's really been an
amazing journey so far.
But just as far
as our show goes,
it's also an interesting, for
everyone other than Andy who
gets to move sort
of chronologically
through this repeated day,
sort of chronologically
through this repeated day, his
journey sort of goes A to Z.
And the rest of us,
I think, the way
I look at it, anyway,
for my character
is, I get to sort of--
my journey goes AB,
ABC, ABCD, ABC--
And so I get to sort of
reveal more about my character
to the audience through the
show, but in a different,
sort of a different way.
So you get to watch two
different ways of following
the same, or many different
ways of tracking the same story.
RAY LEE: And for
the ensemble too,
each day starts
off very similarly.
But there's also these little
differences, with choreography,
and harmonies, and rhythms.
And so they'll be like
the second repeated day,
I'll be on stage, being
like, Becca, what day is it?
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY: I
did that to you yesterday.
I was like, where am I?
Where am I?
What day?
Day two.
RAY LEE: It's day two.
It's day two, go now.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY: Well,
the show is exhausting.
Like, I find in a
show, or the ones
that I've done before,
a lot of the time
it's really tiring at first
because it's very new to you.
And then your body kind
of gets used to it.
And your brain gets used to it.
So your energy
kind of comes back
during the day and other things.
I'm still so tired on this one.
It's an exhausting one.
And then also just not wanting
to embarrass yourself on stage
makes you just not be tired.
Because if you're tired and
you lose it for a second,
you will end up in
the wrong place.
And you'll get hit
by a person, and then
a set piece, then
you'll be on stage going
ah, which I've done like twice.
So it forces you.
JORDAN GRUBB: And what I
was going to say is like,
I, swinging the show,
I cover 11 guys.
So, and I've been on for,
well, after next week,
I'm going on for you,
that'll be my eighth.
So I have to say, this
is the kind of show
that you can't just go on for
someone and think, oh, well,
this is my easy track.
Like, every single
person is in scene work.
Every single person is an
intricate, fully fleshed-out
character in that
town, which is why
I think the show is so special.
Because there's no
one on stage just
like dancing and doing
wings in the background.
It's like it's a--
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
That's a tap step.
JORDAN GRUBB:
--vibrant community
of all these
different characters.
And that's the
cool thing, which I
hope you come see it
if you haven't seen it.
You'll see every single person.
It's so specific
and individualized.
So that keeps me on my toes,
because I'm like someone
different every night.
But yeah.
BARRETT DOSS: And some
of our more fervent fans
will notice if you
miss something.
It's like, oh, god,
they caught me.
SPEAKER: Andy and Barrett,
obviously the both of you
have some pretty
big shoes to fill,
in terms of the maybe
preconceived notions
that people have when
they come see the show,
with Bill Murray
and Andie McDowell.
When you two are filling
this role, when you're
creating your own
character on the stage,
did anything that already
existed in the movie
influence you at all?
Or did you start, either
of you start totally fresh?
ANDY KARL: The
movie is hilarious.
You're welcome, Danny.
But it's also just, like,
I've seen it a million times.
And I'm sure many of
you here have as well.
I think, and when
I first heard they
were doing a musical of it,
I was like, oh, come on man.
You're not going to
be able to top that.
Then I heard the people
that were creating,
including Danny, who's
the original screenwriter.
And then Tim Minchin and Matthew
Warchus, who did "Matilda."
So that's a really sort of
interesting couple of guys
who are gonna, they're
all going to be thinking.
They're all thinking either
outside, inside the box,
around the box, making a box,
thinking that it's going to be.
And so that attracted
me immediately.
I was like, OK, so,
I'll look at the script.
And if it's just going to be
the movie, I can't really.
I'll just be like, fine, but
it's not going to be my role.
There's could be
a million people
who are going be better
than me at doing that.
But it's its own beast.
And that's what's really
great for us is that it's--
the journey of Phil
Connors is epic,
one of the more epic roles
written in musical theater,
I find.
And that's so attractive
because you get to relay so much
of yourself within a show.
And there's so much to
pull from and use on stage.
And I just love what they've
done with Rita as well.
They've expanded her presence.
BARRETT DOSS: Yeah, I think they
did a wonderful, wonderful job
with the female
roles in this show.
We get to, we get to
have a voice in a way
that, I think, in the movie, you
don't get the benefit of what's
happening in Rita's
head while she's
watching him go through
whatever he's going through.
She's not privy to it.
So getting sort of
an inside picture,
I have a very long
extended song and scene
sequence with Andy called, "One
Day," where you really get to,
you get an inside shot of what's
going on with her emotionally.
And it provides a
really great base
to work from for the
rest of the show.
And Andie McDowell is wonderful.
But I really love being--
I don't think of
my character Rita
as the same as her
character Rita at all.
And she came to see the show.
And I don't think she
felt that way either.
I think we were able to
sort of separate ourselves
because it became a different
character in some ways,
when Tim and Danny
expanded her inner life.
ANDY KARL: I haven't
seen Bill at the show.
SPEAKER: I was going to ask.
ANDY KARL: If he's Googling
right now, please come see.
Come on, man.
BARRETT DOSS: I sort of
hope he's like snuck in,
and like he's going to end up
on stage one day, accidentally,
like wearing the Groundhog
suit or something.
He just like walks in.
ANDY KARL: It's
gonna be fantastic.
But that's, but also I
think he and the writers
of the original movie
brought the funny.
And the funny is
still in this show.
I find it goes even
funnier because what you're
watching on stage, how are
they going to make the day
repeat without it being corny?
It's all about, it's slick.
And it's funny.
And it's intros to new
days, which become--
which is interesting.
The audience is ahead and
knows what's happening.
The day is going to repeat.
But they're never
ahead of how we're
going to do it, which
I find beautiful.
Like I don't know how you
guys wrote that and made
that happen.
But it's knock 'em down,
like really funny first act.
Second act goes a little dark,
because he's living that day
over and over again.
Where do you go from there?
They've explored
that territory of how
someone deals with reliving this
same day over and over again.
Because it can be fun
for a little while.
And then it gets to be a drag.
And then what do you do?
And then how is he
going to snap out of it?
And luckily Rita is
there to give him
another way to look at things.
SPEAKER: Talking
about that a second,
I wanted to ask all
of you what you all
thought the actual
interpretation of the show,
what it all represents?
I was reading online.
There were so many,
again, theories.
And hopefully Danny
will, if he's allowed to,
depending on what he's
signed, could tell us
what it actually means.
My, I mean, is it purgatory?
Are you Jesus?
Is this something
happening with--
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
Jesus, that's it.
SPEAKER: Yeah, just Jesus.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
You guessed it.
SPEAKER: Like what's going on?
Anybody, tell me what you think?
ANDY KARL: I want
to hear that guy.
SPEAKER: Danny?
DANNY RUBIN: [LAUGHTER]
Yeah, the groundhog is Jesus.
I think that the story
speaks for itself.
In a way, I don't have to
explain any of the themes,
because everybody comes to
the show with themselves.
And it connects in some way.
Everybody has a
different interpretation.
And every single one seems
stronger than the last.
I have no reason to
define it differently.
It's a very big--
it's just the story of this
person going through this epic
life all in one day.
And I think we all relate to
it within our own language,
so whether it's from a
philosophical point of view,
or a religious point of view,
or just a humanistic view.
It is something
that we all share.
SPEAKER: Well said.
All right.
That was a vague an
answer as I expected, yes.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
DANNY RUBIN: I'm a pro, man.
SPEAKER: Actually that
wasn't the first time
you've been asked.
We have a mic in the
middle of the room here.
If anybody has
questions for Danny
or the cast here on
stage, please line up
and ask those questions, or
get ready to ask questions.
For-- you were going
to say something?
ANDY KARL: Or a song.
SPEAKER: Or a song, if
you want to sing, yeah.
Give your track to the
techs in the back and yeah.
I want to talk quickly--
something, Barrett,
you said a second ago,
about that women have a
voice in this, more than,
more so in the movie.
And that touches
on, like the first--
I talked to a friend
before I saw the show.
And she saw it.
She was like, I don't
know if I really like it
because it was so sexist.
And then I talked to her
again after I saw it.
And she said, you know, the
more I thought about it,
the more like Phil, he
just redeems himself.
You go from one
extreme to the other.
And then on top of
all of that, there's
this new character of Nancy
that didn't exist in the movie.
Like, I guess, Danny, what
was the point of putting,
why did you put Nancy
into this version?
DANNY RUBIN: Well, Nancy
was in the movie, of course.
We just expanded her, giving
her a voice, a point of view.
I think we were trying
to get the audience
to go on Phil's journey.
And by-- we think we've
taken the measure of how
Phil is going to
progress, and how
the show is going to progress.
And right at the beginning
of Act II we do a full stop
and say, oh, you know what?
You were just like Phil.
You were assuming you
understood everything
about this character.
And you knew what she was about.
And we're going to
show you that you
can look at her as a
real person now, not just
as a prop in Phil's story.
And we get that from her.
And you hear the
whole audience sort
of feeling this collective
guilt, like yeah,
I kind of ignored her.
I forgot she was a person too.
And it has a big emotional
impact in driving you
into the second act.
That's what that was about.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
There's this wonderful--
just going with that, with the
audience kind of feeling this
guilt of like, oh, I didn't--
why is she singing?
And we don't need her.
And then you hear the point
of the song, of saying,
you didn't look at me as
anything more than this.
And they go, oh, well,
that's what I was thinking.
That's the whole point
of why the song is there.
But there's this beautiful
like, douche trap,
I like to call it, in the first,
like, two lines of the songs,
when occasionally, on a
rowdy audience, because like,
well, here I am again,
the pretty but naive one,
the perky-breasted,
giggly, one night stand.
[? SPEAKER: ?] Yeah!
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
I guess the word breast
is very exciting for people.
And so sometimes a
dude or something
will be like, yeah, or woohoo!
I'm like, cool,
just wait a second.
You're going to
feel, you're going
to feel really bad about that.
SPEAKER: And so it's, the song
is called, "Playing Nancy."
You're singing it as Nancy.
But Rebecca is singing.
Who is, who, is
mouthing these words?
Where are these
words coming from?
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
You know that when
you were asking about how
many days are in the show,
and Danny was saying it's
really open to interpretation.
I think this show is so
open to interpretation.
I think that's what's
so great about theater
and art in general, is that
like you'll read a book,
or read something, and you
go, this is what it was about.
And the metaphors,
and someone else
will get something
completely different.
And I had someone at stage
door the other day, he's like,
see what you were doing there.
I got it.
I was like, did you?
What was I doing?
He's like, because,
you're Nancy singing it.
But it's really Rebecca.
You're singing it.
And oddly enough, in
my performance of it,
I have never done it
as myself, because just
as an actor, that would
feel very bizarre for me.
I mean, it's bizarre enough
to break the fourth wall
and talk directly to
the audience in a show.
But I can do that as Nancy.
If I turned around as Nancy
and then was like, hey guys,
what's up?
It's like, Rebecca
Faulkenberry here.
I'm going to tell you my
story, which is not my own.
I mean, I can
certainly, very much
relate to this song
in a lot of ways.
But it's not my own words.
It's not my own story.
So I can't do it as myself.
I have to still do
it as the character,
even though I totally see
that interpretation of being
able to do it as
the actor and how
it could relate to an actor.
But I've never
done it as myself.
But a lot of people will,
yeah, a lot of people
will see and be like,
you were doing yourself.
I'm like, no, but I'm glad that
that meant something to you.
RAY LEE: And how many
times do you like,
people expect to
be a certain way,
or expect you to be this person,
and you play along to it.
You know what I mean?
How many times do you
go home and just kind of
want to be yourself?
But you don't have the
people that you can really
be that with.
So I love that song.
I think it calls out, I
don't know, just people.
BARRETT DOSS: But
I'd also like to add
that I think the female
characters in the show have
what I find, personally,
often lacking
in female roles in
musical theater--
that there's an incredible
amount of self-awareness.
So when she is sort
of breaking down
her own experience
of her life, or Rita,
I get to do that in
"One Day," primarily,
and also in "If I had my
Time Again" in a lot of ways,
it feels less about how people
are-- well, in your case,
it's how people are
experiencing you,
but how you get to react to that
and process that information.
And for me, in "One
Day," it feels very much
like I get to comment on
my experience of men--
or of relationships,
rather, not even just men,
but of relationships
as my character,
as opposed to how they feel
about me, which I don't think
gets to happen that often.
So there's what feels
very real about it,
and what I identify with, as
far as Rita and Nancy goes,
is that we all have this
inner life as human beings.
And sometimes it feels
good to just let that
out and share that with people.
And it often feels like,
in musical theater,
women get flattened, become
very two-dimensional.
SPEAKER: A question here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
first, I want to say
thank you very much for coming.
I love the show.
It's really great.
[? BARRETT DOSS: ?] Thank you!
AUDIENCE: My question, I guess
it's maybe for Andy, London
versus New York, did you
find there were differences
in terms of like what
the audience wanted,
what the audience expects?
ANDY KARL: The reaction
was actually very similar,
which I found interesting.
I was told that
audiences in London
don't stand up at the end,
or they're very, very nice.
But they went bananas for it,
which I was like, all right,
man!
International success!
I think because it's
so, like Danny said,
it tells such a human story
that everyone can relate to,
it's like, it singles
out every single body,
every single person in the show.
And they see it for
how they interpret it.
And it's so effective that way.
And I think that's what's
so important about the show
and how it makes London
very similar to here.
There was no cross-continental
divide about have they
seen the movie or not.
And I see a lot of people here
who haven't seen the movie.
And they come to the stage door.
And they're just blown
away by the story.
And I think it
works well, so far.
I don't know about Australia.
I don't know about Germany.
But who knows, maybe
it'll work there.
BARRETT DOSS: I think
Tim's from Australia.
SPEAKER: Next question.
AUDIENCE: I'd also like to say
thank you so much for coming.
I love the show.
My question is, my
sister's in ninth grade.
And her dream is to be
on stage professionally.
Do you have any advice for
someone in that position?
BARRETT DOSS: I've said
this a few times recently.
It's really, I don't
know if she's a singer,
or if she's interested in
musical theater specifically,
but when I've met younger people
at the stage door, I'm always--
who are into musical theater--
I always say, please
don't forget your acting.
Do not forget your acting.
It's like incredibly important.
I think it's easy to
forget when you get a lot--
this going to sound
really shady, but I'm
going to say it anyway--
a lot of like pop stars
who come in to [? show, ?]
it like it's really easy to miss
out on telling real stories,
and understanding how to
recreate basic human emotion,
in place of riffing
and doing all of that,
all those vocal gymnastics.
But acting is so important.
And that's something
that I would
encourage her to keep in mind.
SPEAKER: Anybody else?
JORDAN GRUBB: I'd say
embrace what you do,
what you think is
better than anybody.
Because in this industry,
I feel like there
has to be something
that makes you special.
Because there's
so many people who
can act, and sing, and dance.
But there has to be
something that you
do in particular that
you bring to the table
that nobody else does.
And I think in my first
few years of living here,
I kind of had a
crisis of confidence,
and a crisis of self, and tried
to be this person I wasn't.
And the minute I started
embracing my individuality,
and saw what I did that was
different than everybody
else, that's when the
jobs started coming.
Because I think the
authenticity, in our business,
is important.
And I think it stands out.
RAY LEE: Like,
piggybacking off of that,
don't let anyone box you in.
If I had listened
to the people that
wanted to box me to a type,
with the certain types of shows
I could have done, I wouldn't
be on the stage right now.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
Yeah, going with all,
I mean, it's a hard business.
Everyone knows that.
I remember when
I was auditioning
for colleges and stuff.
You go into every
room and they always
say, if there's anything else
you love, anything else you
can think of doing, go do that.
I'm like, that is so uninspired.
Why would you say that
to a group of artists?
And it wasn't until I
got into the business
I was like, oh, that's
why they say it.
Because truly, it's a very
difficult thing to do.
And I even when my sister
was starting, I was like,
can you see yourself
auditioning, not booking
one job, and waitressing
for at least two years
and having nothing
out of college?
Can you do that and still
enjoy that and think,
but for the possibility that
after two years or maybe longer
I could get something?
Because people go,
yeah, I could do that.
But that won't be me.
Because I'm going to book
something as soon as I
audition.
And you really have to go
through those scenarios.
And if after you think of all
that stuff, you still love it
and you can't see yourself
doing anything else,
then you just figure
out who you are.
You embrace what you do,
learning how to act, especially
for musical theater.
And you just have to like go.
And yeah.
SPEAKER: Very good.
ANDY KARL: Do it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
Danny-- oh, one more question?
Yes, sorry.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I saw the show a few weeks ago.
It was really great.
One of my favorite
sequences was the sequence
at the beginning of Act II, when
you're trying to kill yourself
a bunch of different ways.
[LAUGHTER]
If you see it, it's amazing.
So I was just wondering if
you could reveal a little bit
about how you do it.
Because you climb
up a ladder, and you
appeared downstage
like two seconds later.
[? BARRETT DOSS: ?]
Reveal the magic?
ANDY KARL: Yeah, can't
reveal the magic.
But it is a great number that
took a long time to figure out.
And it's funny because it's
like, one of the harder songs
I do in this show,
but I'm constantly
crawling, and
jumping out of bed,
and I'm appearing on one
stage, and then appearing
on another side of the stage.
Because it's a day that
happens really quickly.
And it happens every
time I kill myself.
And then I wake up in bed
again, alive, to my sadness.
It's just beautiful.
And Paul Kieve, who is another
person we should talk about,
he is our magician for
the show, illusionist.
He figured out a
lot of stagecraft,
and staged distraction.
And it's fun.
And you would think that a
suicide number is not funny.
It actually is
pretty damn funny.
And the song is called "Hope."
So is that an
oxymoron, I believe?
And that's Tim
Minchin's brain at work.
And then the way they staged it,
Matthew Warchus, and how big it
is, and horrible it is.
And then you have to go--
that's what's really great
about it is that,
going through that
is really funny and horrible,
and then coming out of that,
realizing that that's
not the answer.
On to the next
day, what do I do?
But I'm glad you
liked that number.
RAY LEE: And that was one
of the first numbers, too,
I think we learned it.
And Andy was always
like, just wait.
Like, wait, like this got
such a reaction in London.
And we're like OK.
And then once we
started performing,
it was so cool to see the
audience kind of freak
out and just kind
of cheer for it.
So it's a fun one.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
Danny, what's next for you?
What are you writing?
DANNY RUBIN: Lots of things.
I'm trying to do things that--
I live here in Santa
Fe, New Mexico.
And there's so many
talented people here.
I'm working to
write things that I
can do with people
in my own community,
without needing to go to
New York or Los Angeles.
Which I enjoy when it
happens, but I thought
I'd spend a couple
years just trying
to do things closer to home.
SPEAKER: That's why we
invented Google Hangouts,
so we could bring you in
to these types of events.
Yeah, so for the
rest of you here.
DANNY RUBIN: Well done.
SPEAKER: Oh, thank
you, thank you.
For the rest of you here, what
is the one thing-- we're just,
real quickly, we're
short on time--
what is the one
thing that you all
hope audiences
take with them when
they leave after every show?
ANDY KARL: A really good time
and a head full of thoughts.
That's my favorite thing, people
going home thinking about it.
And not only were
they entertained,
but they were asked to
examine their own life.
BARRETT DOSS: Yeah, I mean, I--
JORDAN GRUBB: I was
going to say, I mean,
that they, if you look
around in this year's season,
we're one of the, really
the only comedies,
if not the only
comedy of the season.
So, and I used to get upset
when I would see people
after the show.
And they'd be like, it's so fun.
And I'd be like, no,
I want you to say
it's like the best thing you've
ever seen in your whole life.
But you know what?
It is fun.
Like, if you leave
there and you are happy,
and you are feeling good,
I mean that's theater.
That's why you go
to the theater.
So if you're having
a fun time and you
leave us feeling better
than when you came in,
like, mission accomplished.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY: Yeah,
good theater should affect you
in some way, whether
you go away and it's
leaving you
pondering life stuff,
or you go away and
you think, I just
laughed for two
and a half hours,
or that just made me cry because
it made me contemplate my life,
and where I've gone, and am I
living each day to the fullest.
If it affects you in
some way, and you're not
sitting there bored
out of your mind, which
I guarantee you will
not be at this show,
then it's done its job.
RAY LEE: And we do
diversity right on Broadway.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
Oh yeah, absolutely.
RAY LEE: So I'm
very proud of that.
We aren't all token characters.
We are not token characters.
We are people.
And I always tell people,
come see what we're doing.
BARRETT DOSS: Yeah it's--
and just to piggyback on that,
I agree with what all of us
have said so far.
But I do think that our show,
something that really makes
our show special is not
only gender diversity, age
diversity, race diversity,
size diversity, we really
have created--
this cast is filled with some of
the most talented and hilarious
actors I've ever worked with.
And every single one of
my castmates I feel like
could carry an entire
show on their own.
But everyone gets this moment
to be a part of a group.
And together we make
something really special.
So I hope you will come
see it and enjoy it.
SPEAKER: Wonderful, thank you.
Danny, thank you for joining us.
All of you, thank you.
The August Wilson Theater,
245 West 52nd Street
is where it's playing.
Go visit them online,
groundhogdaymusical.com,
Twitter and Instagram,
@groundhogdaybway.
And then, if you don't
mind, could you close us out
with one more number?
ANDY KARL: Oh do we
have another song?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANDY KARL: Did I give that away?
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
Do we have the track?
I don't know.
SPEAKER: I just
happened to bring it.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY:
Did we sound check this?
ANDY KARL: Did we do this?
Yeah, talk about diversity and
then the six-foot-two white guy
gets up here and starts to,
jeez, close out the show.
BARRETT DOSS: We know what
the show is about, Andy.
ANDY KARL: I think
that's actually--
it's really interesting
to do that part of the,
have that happen.
There's people I wish
would come see the show
and just get a little
clue into a moment
like this, which is, this last
song is called "Seeing You."
And Phil has had
his full journey.
He's gone through
being a jerk, and being
really horrible to
people because he doesn't
want to be in this town.
Then being stuck in this
town with all these people.
And how terrible is that?
And then taking
advantage of that
by being with someone like
Nancy for night after night.
And then realizing
that's not the answer.
There's got to be something new.
And then going to
that dark place
and just wanting to end it all.
And he can't end it.
Then he starts then,
then he actually
has Rita to give them a
clue into saying, well,
actually maybe
you're the lucky one.
You get to live
something new every day.
It's everybody
else that's stuck.
And that's sparked
something in his brain.
Then he becomes altruistic,
and helps people in the town.
And through all this that his
accumulated through this show,
he realizes that everybody
has become a part of his life
and made him a better person.
And he's able to see that
every day, in some nuance,
in everybody.
And it's beautiful.
And this last song is called
"Seeing You," by Tim Minchin.
I don't know how he came
up with these lyrics.
But it's right on the money.
And I'd like to sing that now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDY KARL (SINGING):
Drove out of town,
took right onto a
northbound highway.
Was it really only yesterday?
If I had known what
now I know, maybe I
would have taken a moment,
maybe looked over my shoulder,
maybe shed a tear.
Now I'm here.
A storm blew in, overwhelm me
sometime late this morning.
Think I ignored the warnings.
I've spent a lifetime
seeking signs, reading lines,
trying to forecast the future.
Always staying a day ahead,
well, that was the idea.
But I'm here.
I thought I'd seen it all, was
sure by now I knew this place.
I swear that I knew every
hair, each line upon your face.
I thought the only way to better
days was through tomorrow.
But I know now,
that I know, yes, I
know now, that I know nothing.
But I'm here.
And I'm fine.
And now I'm seeing you
for the first time.
I'm all right.
And I'm seeing you
for the first time.
[INSTRUMENTAL INTERLUDE]
I thought I'd seen it all, was
sure by now I knew this place.
I swear that I knew every
hair, each line upon your face.
I thought the only way to better
days was through tomorrow.
But I know now that I
know, yes, I know now
that I know that I'm here.
And I'm fine.
And I'm seeing you
for the first time.
I'm all right.
And I'm seeing you
for the first time.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
ANDY KARL: Thank you
all for being here.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY: Thanks.
BARRETT DOSS: Yay!
SPEAKER: One more big
round of applause.
REBECCA FAULKENBERRY: Thank you.
BARRETT DOSS: Thank you.